this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm going to do my best to use the
the mouse as a pointer here so that
everyone can see in both locations it's
my great pleasure to give an overview of
our research I'm going to touch on a
number of projects that we've got going
but there are a number of projects that
I don't have time to get to and I'm
going to break up my talk into four
sections here so here's an an overview
of what I'm going to talk about starting
with the most applied and ending with
the most basic aspects of our research
I'll start by talking about the overall
agronomic system of growing shrub willow
as a bioenergy crop give an overview of
our breeding program and some of the
unique aspects of breeding willow I'll
talk about our emerging resources for
mapping in willow both QTL mapping and
Association mapping and then get to a
project that's funded by the Department
of Energy their feedstock genomics
program where we're trying to look at
the genomic basis for heterosis in
triploid hybrids of willow so this is
the typical land that we target to grow
willow on willow as a pioneer species
will do well on marginal AG land and it
is a crop that we aim to avoid the
conflict between food and fuel by
targeting underutilized or abandoned AG
land so this is a site at Vernon Verona
Sherrill High School near Rome New York
that is typical of a lot of the
abandoned or underutilized AG land in
the Northeast and Upper Midwest
with willow we can convert that
marginally profitable land back to more
conventional agriculture although very
low input and very low labor requiring
agriculture so we planted willow at the
high school here in 2010 I'm sorry in
spring of 2009 and this is what it
looked like by October of 2010 at that
high school they have a very active FFA
program where they make maple syrup and
they're actually harvesting the willow
to burn in their evaporators while they
make maple syrup so here is an overview
of the willow agronomic system we are
aiming to develop conservation tillage
as a method of site preparation you see
here that the first thing we have to do
is kill the existing vegetation and as a
part of that for both weed management
nutrient management Erik Fabio and my
lab is doing a lot of work on first
planting cover crops as a part of that
site preparation but we've also been
working with Agron etics a company in
Rochester to use GPS guidance for zone
tillage which is what you see here
followed up by GPS guided planting using
one of these mechanical planters this
one was built in Denmark so we're
planting dormant cuttings stem cuttings
here these are whips that are about 7 or
8 feet long that the planter will cut
into 8 inch pieces and push into the
ground as it moves along we plant in a
double row system with 30 inches between
the rows with either a 5 or a 6 foot
alley between those double rows with 2
feet between the plants giving us a
planting density of about 6000 plants
per acre
those plants will those cuttings will
root fairly readily and push buds to
make new shoots that will grow about
five or six feet tall by the end of that
establishment year and we take advantage
of the natural biology of willow by
cutting them back or coppicing them
which then stimulates vigorous regrowth
in the start of that second year so
while we discard the biomass that's
produced in that establishment year once
those plants are established they will
vigorously re-sprout after each cut back
by the end of that first year after
coppice or the second year of production
on that site we typically have growth of
twelve to fifteen feet tall and our
normal production cycle would go on a
three-year harvest rotation by which
time the plants are 20 to 25 feet tall
we harvest in the winter time typically
we're planting on poorly drained sites
that are wet so in the winter it is an
advantage to have the ground frozen it's
a time when forage harvesters like this
New Holland forage harvester are not
typically being used so that harvesting
operation can switch off their corn
harvesting head and put on a willow
cutter head and continue to use that
machinery through the winter it's a time
when we need chips for heating and
obviously it's the time when the plants
are dormant so it's a good time to cut
them back and you see that all the
leaves have fallen so and and returned
back to the soil recycling those
nutrients in the leaves back to the to
the soil that those woodchips then would
be collected blown into a truck taken to
the conversion facility here you see a
whole truck dumper at a power plant just
north of Rome New York where they're
piling up chips to load into their
boiler again that following spring the
plants would vigorously re-sprout
starting a new growth cycle new year a
new three-year Harbor cycle we modeled
the economics based on seven of these
three year harvest cycles but there's
good evidence from Sweden that yield is
maintained for at least 10 harvest
cycles so there's really no no end in
sight in the productivity of a willow
plantation once it's established that
biomass can be used in a number of
different conversion processes here in
New York State we have three wood fired
power plants and willow is more than
adequate fuel for those power plants
there is an emerging market for
feedstocks for liquid transportation
fuels and in fact the US government has
set some very aggressive targets to
produce twenty billion gallon twenty
billion billion gallons of advanced
renewable biofuels by 2022 were nowhere
close to getting to that point because
the technology for that conversion is
lagging behind and it is quite expensive
at this point compared to petroleum
another viable market that we have in
the Northeast is to use wood for
renewable heating and this is a
small-scale boiler that we've installed
here in Geneva to heat two of our
buildings entirely fueled by willow
willow can also readily be pelletized
and used in in pellet stoves or pellet
boilers we've done a fair amount of work
to look at the wood composition of
willow that composition will be critical
for many of these liquid biofuels
conversion methods it's not so critical
but but even still the thermochemical
conversion combustion or thermo chemical
conversion to liquid transportation
fuels will also have its own optimal
biomass composition and we see quite a
bit of variation in biomass
position among our different varieties
in our breeding program so unfortunately
that's about all that I have time to
talk about in terms of biomass
composition but it is a critical trait
for these different conversion systems
just to emphasize that willow is a
viable commercial crop and that the
government is invested in developing
willow as a crop in 2011 the USDA
initiated a program to plant to provide
planting subsidies for willow in
northern New York specifically this
overall program is called the biomass
crop assistance program and our area in
New York
among these nine counties I believe it
is specifically to pay 75% of the
establishment costs to plant willow
provide an annual land payment and to
link the harvest of that willow with
conversion in local power plant
facilities these three would fired power
plants that I talked about one at Fort
Drum called Black River this one just
north of Rome the line sale power plant
and one near Messina the Chateauguay
power plant those power plants are then
paying a contract price set by the B cap
program so we have about 1200 acres
about 500 hectares or so of shrub willow
in commercial production in New York
State there is about 20,000 acres in
production in Sweden in Denmark in
England growing production in Poland and
Ukraine Hungary so it is a viable
commercial crop being developed for
renewable energy so that sort of
summarizes our production system our
agronomics again just want to point out
that
there are significant barriers to
adoption of Willow including the high
cost of establishment the cost of
cutting production is a limiting factor
compared to seed production such such as
for switchgrass it is a system that
needs specialized planting and
harvesting equipment which most of which
is built in Europe New Holland has
invested in developing their own willow
cutter head that is matched with their
self-propelled forage harvesters but
still there is a lack of commercially
available planting and harvesting
equipment the key point that leads into
the next section of my talk is that the
economics of biomass production of
willow is dramatically improved when we
get increased yields per acre as you can
imagine so breeding for improved yield
for more stable production across
marginal sites there's a critical factor
for the long term adoption of willow as
a renewable energy source so I'm going
to move into talking about our willow
breeding program
first of all establishing our goals
first goal well the first three goals
are all yield as I just mentioned
fitting that into the economics of the
system the more you yield per acre the
more we will encourage adoption it is a
perennial crop that will stay in the
ground for as long as 30 years so
long-term durable pest and disease
resistance is critical as I mentioned
wood composition is a critical aspect
for matching feedstocks to conversion
technology and we also always need to be
conscious of the cost of cutting
production and stool form and plant form
crown form branching for example is a
critical aspect for efficient cutting
production as well as harvesting
efficiency we're now moving into looking
at
aspects of stress tolerance as well for
particularly marginal sites and I'll
show you that one type of site we're
very interested in is reclaimed mine
land in Pennsylvania and West Virginia
so keeping all of these goals in mind an
underlying premise that we work with is
that we want to maintain a genetically
diverse suite of pedigrees among our
commercially deployed cultivars since we
are planting clonal material we always
want to maintain a high level of genetic
diversity in the field to hedge against
any individual cultivar failure due to
pests and disease susceptibility so our
overall approach and strategy in
breeding willow is to rely on species
hybridization and the hybrid vigor or
heterosis that we observe in species
hybrids so here I've got pictures of
three people have been critical over the
years in actually doing the controlled
Paula nations and the crosses that we've
done starting in 1998 and 99 rich cop
who was one of my PhD students at SUNY
ESF really developed our techniques for
extracting polland doing controlled
pollination x' in the greenhouse did our
initial hybridizations and many of our
current commercial cultivars are
genotypes that rich bred many of which
we've now patented Jim Cameron took over
for rich and did a number of very
successful crosses in 2002 through 2005
which I'm going to talk about as well
working as a postdoc in my lab first at
ESF and then helping me move here to
Cornell and more recently Sam napkin was
a Hobart student helped out in the
greenhouse over the last two years
helping to manage and maintain thousands
of seedlings in the Green
he was a real asset to us so one of the
features of Salix and I'm going to
distinguish Salix from populist the two
main species in the salic AC one of the
features of Salix is the tremendous
species diversity that we see in that
genus there are over 300 species of
Salix while in populous there only I
think 34 different species and they
range from dwarf sprawling alpine shrubs
to you know the weeping willow or black
willow trees that we're familiar with we
work exclusively with species in the sub
genus Beatrix which are primarily shrub
form willow they grow with multiple
small diameter stems never really
achieving a single stem like the tree
form willows do and in particular we're
working primarily with in the section
helix and making crosses with the
section Dimond but you see there is
great potential for species
hybridization here another feature
that's unique about Salix especially
compared to populous is the abundance of
polyploidy across the genus and in this
particular scheme of species that we
work with in our breeding program you'll
see that Salix my B Anna from Japan is
tetraploid a natural tetraploid and
salic Stasik Latos very common in the
european breeding programs is hexaploid
while all the other species here are
diploid i'm going to talk about some of
our genomics and we focused in on Salix
purpurea as a reference genome for our
initial genome sequencing efforts it is
a central species in our breeding
program it is consistent diploid but you
can see that it is a good species to
hybridize with many of the other species
in Section helix and also across
sections here with members of women
I'm also going to talk about in our work
on triploids crosses between Salix
purpurea and Salix my biana as well as
crosses between Salix vim and Alice
which is the main species in the
European willow breeding programs and
Salix my Vienna as you can imagine these
crosses between chat Reploids and
diploid x' will generate triploid
progeny and that will be a ongoing theme
here through the rest of my talk so
since 1998 this is a list of all of the
different species combinations that
we've been able to produce over the
years I've underlined the species that
are triploids so you see a significant
number of those progeny are triploid but
we have the capability to combine
multiple species here and and our long
term strategy is for overall improvement
of diploid species independently of
tetraploid x' to make that final f1
hybridization between the diploid and
the tetraploid generating triploid
progeny since I moved to Cornell in 2009
we produced about 10,000 seedling
progeny representing our next round of
potential cultivars for selection so up
till now we've largely been relying on
phenotypic selection and the other
willow breeding programs the main ones
being in England and in Sweden as well
have been relying on phenotypic
selection and this is our overall scheme
that we've been using first to do those
controlled pala Nations in the
greenhouse producing seed that we
immediately so and get started in the
greenhouse in midsummer we print
transplant those out to the field so
here we're talking about thousands of
progeny out planted to the field here as
you see we're doing
in our nursery beds here in Geneva and
then typically we would evaluate
seedlings within family rows in those
nursery beds and make a selection on the
order of 10 to 15% within the best
families and then propagate those to
replicated selection trials and these
have only been on single sites and here
we're talking about on the order of 60
to 80 genotypes that are advanced into
these selection trials finally from
analysis of those selection trials we
select on the order of 12 to 15
genotypes to advance into regional yield
trials where it's critical to evaluate
genotype by environment interactions to
look at their response to varying pest
and disease pressure on different sites
their response to different soil types
and climate conditions so overall that
phenotypic selection process takes us to
regional yield trials within four to
seven years and our overall cycle of
identifying new cultivars runs on a
cycle of about 10 to 12 years so we went
through that process again using
genotypes that rich cop bred in
1998-1999 got those into yield trials
that were planted from 2005 up through
2008 across New York State and through
collaboration across many parts of North
America all the way from Montreal Quebec
out to Waseca Minnesota just south of
Minneapolis even in the Upper Peninsula
of Michigan so those are our target
regions the Northeast and Upper Midwest
and southern parts of Canada
and you can see when we look at the
yield of the top five genotypes in each
of these trials and compare them with
the foundation breeding material that we
had in Syracuse originally and yield
trials that were managed by my
colleagues to in Vulcan Larry Abrahamson
those new cultivars from first round of
breeding produced about a 30 to 35
percent increase in yield overall so
that's our success and one round of
breeding through capturing heterosis of
species hybrids among those cultivars
that we tested in those yield trials we
have now patented eight of them and
those are licensed by the Research
Foundation of SUNY two very active and
collaborative nursery producer many of
you know through his primary business
which is producing wine grape cuttings
dennis rack at double-a willow so he now
is the main source of planting stock for
commercial growers in north america with
production capacity of about 30 million
cuttings per year that's enough for five
to six thousand acres and willow each
year I just want to highlight again that
many of these cultivars are hybrids
between the diploid Salix women Alice
and tetraploid salix my Vienna or
between the diploid Salix purpurea and
tetraploid Salix my Vienna okay we have
now continued to advance our breeding
program and our next round of genetic
selection trials was planted here in
Geneva in 2008 again with 75 genotypes
we harvested that the first time in 2011
and from those genotypes bred in 2002
and 2005 and some in 2001 again we have
captured about a 15%
increase in yield compared to our
current commercial cultivars so these
are now have now been advanced to
regional yield trials to do that same
type of genotype by environment
interaction testing but now we're
getting into the yields of 17 dry metric
tons per hectare per year that are
really going to have an impact on the
economics of the system so I am very
fortunate to be a member of USDA funded
project to develop willow and
switchgrass as bioenergy crops in the
Northeast US it's led by Penn State and
our contribution to this project which
we call new bio was to establish a new
round of regional yield trials through
collaboration with SUNY ESF double-a
willow and Fredonia folks at Penn State
Marvin Hall and John Carlson including a
site on reclaimed mine land
collaboration with Steve de Fazio at
West Virginia University and with Ray
Miller up in Escanaba Michigan so we
expect that once we have the results of
this new round of yield trial we will
advance at least a couple new cultivars
to commercial production now we
recognize that our potential to capture
those yield improvements is getting
smaller and smaller meaning that we need
to be more precise in our selection
methods and we have recently moved to
planting to not relying so heavily on
unreplicated performance in these family
row trials in nursery beds but rather
propagating all of the genotypes that we
produce in a family and testing them now
in replicated trials as you can imagine
these are getting very large
when you pick almost 300 genotypes or
here we have 1100 genotypes replicated
in four reps I would love to do this on
multiple sites but even on one site this
is a lot of plots to go out and measure
and evaluate but that is what we have
done here in 2013
Fred Goucher is my PhD student is
managing this trial and craig carlson my
third PhD student is managing this trial
both here in Geneva okay so to summarize
our current strategy for breeding salic
hybrids is to capture heterosis through
species hybridization especially to
produce triploids that our initial
selections produce some impressive yield
gains but in order to maintain those we
will need to get more precise and
produce larger families with better
overall precision of selection which we
think we can gain and also gain
advantages of early selection by
developing genomic tools and developing
marker-assisted selection so really what
we're talking about is whether we can
pick a needle from a haystack right
whether we can pick those particular
genotypes out of thousands that we can
produce through breeding that have all
of the traits and additive genes
combined in that one single superior
genotype so I wish I could just look at
the pots on the greenhouse bench and
pick out that one needle out of the
haystack of seedlings but again we can't
do that by eye we need to develop
genomic tools that can do that for us so
we were very fortunate to collaborate
with folks at do e especially jerry
tuscan at Oak Ridge National Lab and his
relying on his connections with the
joint genome Institute
of do-e who have invested resources to
sequence Salix purpurea as a reference
for Salix so we selected one of our
female clones again a central clone in
our breeding program did entirely
Illumina sequencing that was done at jgi
the assembly was done by high Boateng at
the craig Venter Institute in Chris
towns lab and we now have released that
first assembly and fight his own version
10 this is the D OE genomics website so
we're up to here if your genome jockey
we're up to scaffolds with an L 50 of
190 Kb but we still have about 90 300
scaffolds in our assembly so basically
what that means is using this short read
Illumina technology we have assembled
the genome but still it's in a large
number of small pieces are our ultimate
aim is to assemble all of those
sequences into chromosome scale
assemblies but that is going to take
some additional sequencing work which we
are undertaking as we speak what we have
been able to do is to take advantage of
this great technology developed in ed
buckler's lab at is in the USDA down in
Ithaca are called genotyping by
sequencing this high resolution high
density marker system can be developed
without any prior genomic sequence
knowledge it's very cheap per sample so
we can get thousands of markers for only
$35 per sample and we were very lucky to
get in early on as ad
and Ravel's Shire and Sharon Mitchell
down in Ithaca we're developing this
technique to develop GBS markers for
Salix purpurea which has now helped us
in developing a genetic map and
improving our overall genome assembly so
what we did was to apply GBS to an f2
family fairly large 495 progeny of Salix
purpurea developed using our reference
genome 9 9 406 as the original
grandmother so that we can develop we
produced in collaboration with Steve de
Fazio and Eli Rodgers Melnick at West
Virginia University a high-resolution
genetic map of this pedigree we could
then take those GBS markers and align
them to our scaffolds in the assembly
and using the powers of the genetic
mapping could then assemble our
scaffolds into chromosome scale sudha
molecule level molecules so we have
about 75 or 80 percent of the assembly
now aligned into these 19 sunna
molecules equivalent to the 19
chromosomes of Salix what I'm showing
here in this figure is the alignment of
the Salix map to the poplar genome and
here is the alignment of the Salix
sequence assembly scaffolds aligned to
the genetic map some things that we've
learned in where we continue to analyze
the genome assembly is that there are
some major chromosome rearrangements
between Salix and populous big one here
is between chromosome 1 and 16 there's a
fusion between poplar
Salix a major chunk of poplar chromosome
1 is fused with Salix chromosome 16 we
also see some important translocations
and I'm going to tip my hand here and
say that we have been mapping the sex
determination locus and actually that
sex determination locus sits in a region
that is transload translocated from
poplar chromosome 19 to Salix chromosome
15 so we're we're learning some
important differences between poplar and
Willow having the genome assembly here
there's a lot more analysis that we will
be doing in that in the near future at
JDI they also sequence some of the
express genes so that we could develop a
high-quality annotation of all of the
genes in the in the genome doing RNA
seek from eight different tissue
libraries made from five different
tissues here basically what we see is
that there are slightly fewer genes
expressed in Salix than there are in
poplar but still we have a pretty good
library or or annotation of the 38,000
or so genes expressed in Willow okay the
next step is to use that genetic map
those GBS markers and the genome
sequence to develop mapping populations
so that we can relate phenotype to
genotype so that we can start to work
towards marker-assisted selection and we
are using the complementary approaches
of both QTL mapping using by parental
populations with Association mapping
using a diverse collection of Salix
purpurea so we are now going back to
that same f2 family which has a pretty
large number of progeny and craig
carlson
here has planted that out in a
replicated trial here in Geneva so that
we can start to characterize traits of
importance for biomass production for
willow biology and map them into this
high resolution by parental mapping
population we've done that on something
that some of the simple traits already
since willow is dioecious we have been
able to map the locus controlling sex in
willow as I mentioned before it maps to
a single spot on chromosome 15 and in
fact we see that Salix purpurea and
perhaps all Salix are using a ZW sex
determination system that means that the
email is the header hgroup hetero
comedic sex the male is easy while at
least populous striker carpa uses an XY
sex determination system so again there
are some interesting contrast there
between poplar and Salix and in the
overall evolution of Daichi and whether
that XY and z w system can flip-flop
back and forth or at what point in the
divergence between poplar and Salix did
it flip-flop that's just one example of
the types of traits that we can map
using this powerful system now Fred
Goucher has been working to develop
Association mapping or genome a
genome-wide Association study or gene
wass using the collection of Salix
purpurea that we have assembled from
across the Northeast so we have it's a
relatively small Association mapping
population only 112 genotypes but we
have planted that on replicated trials
here in Geneva out at the Clairol
station in Portland and in collaboration
with Steve de Fazio down in Morgantown
West Virginia we have fully genotype
that collection with GBS
and for the last two years fred has been
working on phenotyping those populations
with some of the key traits again that
we're interested in for biomass
production including as you can imagine
stem height stem diameters stem numbers
we're very interested in wood density we
use high resolution thermo gravimetric
analysis to determine the composition of
cellulose hemicellulose lignin and ash
in the wood and we've also been able to
measure leaf area use a SPAD meter to
measure leaf nitrogen and a parameter to
measures to model conductance we've also
developed some techniques to look at
overall crown form and growth form also
looking at pest and disease resistance
which aren't on these which which isn't
on this list again some of the
additional hits that fred has been able
to map and he's actively working on
mapping all of those traits right now
again a simple one is to look at sex
determination and the mapping in the
Association population matches that that
we see in the by parental QTL population
pointing to a single major locus on
chromosome 15 so that highlights how we
can use these two different mapping
populations to complement one another
and to confirm the hits that we're
getting in both types of mapping some
other hits that fred has come up with
here we see a significant hit for
variation and stem height so as we look
at these Manhattan plots each of these
different colors represents the 19
different chromosomes in Salix and each
dot represents a a snip or a marker on
that chromosome as it gets higher in
this plot represents a higher level of
significance for the correlation between
variation in that trait and that
particular
thought on the genome or snip so looking
at hits for stem height here he has some
snips that are significant and map to
this very specific region of the genome
which we can map using I think this was
done with about 25,000 GBS markers
mapping those snips between glycosyl
hydrolases a cellulose which we now need
to follow up on and see how they are
involved in regulating stem height
another hit for hemi cellulose content
quantified by TGA here we see
significant snips here in a sugar
nucleotide epimer rice
potentially involved again in sugar
nucleotide conversions during cell wall
biosynthesis but this gives us some
targets some candidate genes that we can
follow up on look at their patterns of
expression look at the variation in
alleles in our association population
and to see how those different alleles
are influencing the traits involved okay
so to summarize we have a pretty good
genome assembly in place right now
produced through a good collaboration
with the joint genome Institute of do e
we continue to advance those genomic
resources we have developed both QTL and
association mapping populations that can
complement each other the big issue the
big the most expensive part now is
phenotyping those populations with
thousands of plots out in the field but
we have great potential for identifying
good candidates for marker-assisted
selection now the final part of my talk
is that I think that Salix also
represents a unique system for the study
of heterosis and that having these
genomic resources gives us the potential
to probe
of the genomic basis for heterosis in
this highly heterozygous species which
has undergone no domestication up up to
this point and also displays heterosis
in across ploidy levels or in triploids
okay so I'm going to take you back to
this 2008 selection trial which had 75
genotypes and if we look at the yield
the mean yield of those 75 genotypes in
that trial and look at the ploidy
the vast majority of the upper 50th
percentile of genotypes in that trial
were triploid and the overall yield of
the triploids was significantly and
dramatically greater than the yield of
the diploid in that trial the yield of
the tetraploid is not significantly
different but when we look at some of
the other traits like stem number or
aspects of biomass composition we do see
significant differences between the
triploids and the tetraploid the bottom
line here again is that we are seeing
dramatically better performance in
triploids compared to diploid
so we want to ask what is the genomic
basis for that heterosis that we're
capturing so just to sort of define what
we mean by heterosis the classic example
is in maize where if you cross one end
bread line with another embroid line you
see that the progeny display either mid
parent heterosis meaning that their mean
performance is better than the average
performance of the two parents or you
may see better parent heterosis meaning
that the progeny are better than even
the best the better of the two parents
right and there are some classic models
to explain
how that heterosis is occurring whether
it's occurring through a dominance model
or through an over dominance model the
dominance model meaning that there are
complimentary additive alleles which
come together in hybrid to make that
hybrid even better than its parents or
in the in the other model the over
dominance model where the presence of a
heterozygote even at a single gene can
confer superior performance to that
hybrid over its two parents the main
difference being that in the Mays
example those are inbreds highly
homozygous inbred lines that have been
bred for decades here we're seeing
heterosis when we cross two wild
accessions that are highly heterozygous
and when we cross a diploid with a
tetraploid to get a triplet right so the
approach that we're taking is to look at
the patterns of gene expression in the
triploid progeny and to what extent is
the inheritance of gene expression in
the hybrid progeny non-additive meaning
different from the mid parent average
can we identify allele-specific
expression inherited from one of the
other parents and the obvious question
would be is there a dosage effect in
those triploid Hart progeny that are
getting two copies from the tetraploid
parent and one copy from the diploid
parent finally are those differentially
expressed genes responsible for
heterosis so can we correlate the
patterns of gene expression that we see
with phenotype in the field or in the
greenhouse so as we look at quantifying
patterns of gene expression this is a
scheme that we use first of all sort of
the default is when
gene expression equals in I'm sorry in
parent one is equivalent to that in
parent to hear parent one will always be
the maternal parent so when there's no
differential expression and the progeny
gene expression is at that same level we
classify that as additive that's not so
interesting to us the more interesting
case is when there is differential gene
expression between the two parents here
the mother has higher expression than
the father here the mother has lower
expression than the father if the
progeny expression hits the midpoint
between the parental levels of
expression again we would call that
additive if the progeny expression is
equivalent to the high parent or the low
parent then that's an example of
dominance or if it is below the low
parent or above the high pair again that
is a non additive pattern of expression
an example of under dominance or over
dominance so in the cases where we see
differential expression between our two
parents we will classify the expression
in the progeny according to these five
categories okay in order to test to look
at differential patterns of expression
we've developed these eight families
first of all an f1 family of Salix
purpurea that same f2 family of Salix
purpurea that i've talked about and then
reciprocal crosses between purpurea and
Bhim and Alice here purpurea as the
mother or demon Alice as the mother and
then triploid families representing
crosses between purpurea my be Anna or
between Bhim and Alice and my be Anna
and we have planted typically a hundred
progeny from each of these families in
the field and the experiment that I'm
going to
to you was done by selecting ten random
progeny from six of these eight families
growing those in the greenhouse and then
we extracted RNA to use for RNA seek
okay we extract a tissue from extracted
RNA from two different tissues either
from shoot tips or from stem Internode's
and map those reads back to our genome
assembly did statistics to look for
differential patterns of expression and
we will continue on unfortunately don't
have time to talk about this today but
use some additional techniques to look
at allele-specific expression okay just
to quickly go through some of the main
conclusions the first one being that
triploids express more genes than
diploid so when we look at the total
counts of genes that are expressed in
the triploid progeny we see that there
are thousands of genes expressed at
thousands of additional genes expressed
in the triploids than in the diploid so
that may be one clue right there
interestingly the overall levels of
expression tend to be lower in the
progeny than they are in the parents now
when we cluster the patterns of gene
expression between progeny and the mid
parent values here the first level of
clustering that we see is distinguishing
progeny from those mid parent values so
the greatest level of difference in
expression is between progeny and
parents the next level of cross
clustering is at the level of tissue and
finally sort of the bottom level of
clustering is at the level of species so
it's interesting that
the greatest difference in the gene
expression patterns that we're seeing
are differences between progeny and
parents even greater than differences
between species to put that another way
we see greater differential gene
expression between the mid parent and
the progeny than we see between the two
parents which are different species
right so here when we compare one parent
to another male to female you see that
most of the dots are fairly close to the
one-to-one line but when we compare
progeny to bin parent now we have a much
broader sorry much broader scattering of
spots representing greater differential
gene expression between progeny and
parent okay the next thing was to
quantify among those genes which are
differentially expressed between the two
parents
okay so statistically which genes for
which parent one is not equal to parent
two and as you can see here the
triploids and the interspecific diploid
x' have far more genes showing
differential expression between the two
parents than our Salix purpurea families
so of about 35,000 genes here as many as
7,000 genes are differentially expressed
between the two parents okay so now for
those differentially expressed genes and
and they're more in the chute tip than
there are in the inter node for those
differentially expressed genes we fit
them into those five categories are they
maternally dominant paternally dominant
over dominant or under dominant or are
they in that sort of default additive
case where they hit the mid parent mean
and the interesting thing here is that
those genes that show additive
expression
are very very few in fact the vast
majority are showing highly maternal
dominant patterns of expression so again
that may be a clue to the heterosis that
we're seeing in species hybrids in Salix
we see more in chew tip than we do in
inter note finally what we want to go on
to look at is can we actually look at
the allele coming from the mother and
the expression of the mother's allele
compared to the father's allele we
needed to identify snips or sequence
differences between those two parents so
we have now resequenced all of our
parents in this experiment and you see
we see quite a few differences snips
that we can rely on to give us as many
as 18,000 snips so we can start to sort
out allele specific patterns of
expression between mother and father
okay so to summarize this final
experiment that I described there is
greater differential gene expression in
triploids than in our our Salish
purpurea diploid x' that the gene
expression levels in the progeny show a
strong pattern of maternal parent
dominance which is very interesting the
next step that we need to move on to is
to start to phenotype individuals in the
field and in the greenhouse and
correlate the patterns of gene
expression and perhaps expression of
individual genes that are differentially
expressed with the heterotic phenotypes
that we can quantify in the greenhouse
or in the field so that's all hey I have
time to talk about today I want to
express my sincere thanks for all the
folks who have worked in my lab over the
years my three current PhD students Fred
Eric and Craig and Kurt my tech
mission Michelle Sarah P Leah who was my
graduate student and and then postdoc
here in Geneva who did a lot of work to
develop our methods of analysis of wood
composition and my collaborators Jerry
Tuscan at Oak Ridge Steve de Fazio at
West Virginia Chris town at craig Venter
Institute I mentioned my collaborators
at Michigan State Penn State and SUNY
ESF as well as all of the crews that
we've had here working with us in the
summer primarily here in Geneva so I
will stop there thank you for your
attention and I'd be happy to answer any
questions including those from Ithaca if
you unmute your microphone so thanks
mother is related to the connection with
the plastic plastic genomes and
therefore photosynthesis and everything
else all the other machinery do you
think that is reasonable that they
communicate better because they've
evolved together yeah so just to repeat
Gennaro's question the question is
whether the strong maternal dominance of
expression that we're seeing may be due
to the influence of the chloroplast
genome which is inherited from the
mother I think that's an excellent
hypothesis that we can test him and
Craig I know is very interested in
testing that hypothesis and has looked
at the expression of chloroplast genes
also in our earnings data
the other question is whether there is
some epigenetic in particular involved
in this maternal dominant expression and
the maternal dominus let me re-emphasize
does not matter which species right so
whether it's a leaf em analysis the
mother or sails appropriate is the
mother it is maternal dominant it is not
a species specific hers
Larry you know it's some species like
potato would make a cross between the
template that's Italy you get a
predefined frequency of such a points to
unreduced or diploid gametes so I'm
wondering if your your triplets what
you've done to confirm that they're
triplets and wondering whether diploid
Cabot's occurring on the sale of species
yes versus question is how how detailed
have we done to confirm that they're
turquoise at this point we've only done
flow cytometry we've done repeated flow
cytometry because that technique can be
inconsistent from run to run we have not
ruled out that there could be different
levels of aneuploidy I think we can go
back
most specifically through our GPS data
to look for GPS markers that might
indicate an employee of a particular
chromosome so yes we do see unreduced
gametes and say--let's because sometimes
we are able to get progeny from our
triplets so that's probably the best
evidence that I can give you that there
is some cheeky control of almost a
number of maintained
yeah no you sure that there's some
native polyploid tetraploid and
hexaploid i just wondering are those
Lala all on its auto
polyploid and if it's auto again that
would be question we like to what post
information over there
the game is an introduction you know how
that might complicated that the
operating system yeah I I don't know how
detailed anyone has characterized so the
question is whether they the polyploid
czar a low or following I'm not aware
whether anyone has done any detailed
descriptions of those but I would assume
that they are auto public employees
Thomas and then maybe we should go
together okay it's all that reproduction
so he said that having several
phenotypes in the fields is is superior
to a single one but it strikes me if you
say you had three genotypes in the field
and one of them got like that now you're
in a field with only 2/3 of a crop which
it can't possibly be economical isn't it
better to just wiped out the whole thing
and start over it and get a one of you
types okay okay so so if you have picked
the one best yielding cultivar and have
planted all of your fields with that one
and it gets wiped out then you have no
video right if you have planted three
and you planted them in blocks are made
than this field that one this field and
another dad yet your one field is wiped
out you can replant it or that one block
is whited out you can run finally the
standard in Ireland now and in England I
think is the plant in random mixtures
and over time the superior genotypes
went out the rust susceptible genotypes
diminish and you end up with a lower
number of plants per acre but what we
found is that that does not severely
impact the world how much percent plant
lost and alone
I think you can go down probably 30% in
spam density and still realize any
questions for Ithaca there are going to
be $7 commercially so the first question
is is any fertilizer lack the total
because you're removing a lot of
nutrients from the soil that's a grown
man it would seem to me that long-term
plans bility to take up nutrients would
be a considerable factor in the total
yield but you never mentioned about the
visiting plants to look at you need for
the ability to take nutrients yeah thank
you Peter that's an excellent question
and it's one of the aspects of our
research that I had to drop out from
this seminar but is the main topic of
Eric Fabio's research so he has done
fertilizer trials using some of our
current commercial cultivars in the
greenhouse has been looking at the
impact of nutrients nutrient by cover
crops early establishment of willows in
the field and again has been analyzing
yields from across now 24 different
trials to correlate soil nutrient levels
with yield and growth parameters there
are conflicting data in the literature
some papers which say there's very
little influence of
Eliezer I believe that there is an
influence of fertilizer especially in
the early harvest cycles but that it
seems fairly likely that after a certain
amount of time a cycling of nutrients
will be established in Willow
plantations
so that long-term fertilizer application
may not be necessary
and you'll get I think that's all the
questions we have here okay thank you
one more so J is asking if Willis or
Michael Rizzo and yes they are and
they're rather promiscuous they can form
associations with multiple different
types of categorizing that's a very
interesting question and again ties in
with the need for fertilizer but it's
one that needs a lot more okay one more
of a lot of you are using
whether you are using all kinds of
marker
yeah so we have used both pseudo test
cross mail current back cross markers
and female parent back cross markers as
well as inter cross markers I think in
that initial analysis we had about 8300
markers and I think about 3300 of them
were inter cross markers and something
like this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu